[Musica]
ditemi voi se sta musica non incita alle
cose zozze allora andiamo su italiano
prima cosa visto che stiamo giocando un
gioco di logica quindi essendo io già
limitato in inglese almeno in italiano
va bene
oggi siamo su un attimo un attimo se ha
un suo si prostra musica mi sta un po
triturando i maroni perfetta siamo su un
maestro di logica che un gioco che si
scarica si gioca non avreste mai visto
che genio
partiamo benissimo tocca al bottone blu
per iniziare il gioco vai scopi
quindi sono quelle cose che tentano di
farti sbagliare ma io sono troppo
sveglio per sbagliare scoppia palloncini
rossi la sinistra a destra a sinistra
sinistra e destra let's go
mi chiamo ora avanti brucia i fiammiferi
da destra a sinistra me la cavo non
faccio così schifo contate che vivo da
solo da tre anni quindi se riesco a fare
queste cose vuol dire che non mi sono
ancora suicidato perfetto tocca le palle
dalla più leggera la più pesante
la più leggera penso sia questa poi c'è
quella da tennis
poi c'è quella da basket poi c'era la
busi let's go veri che poi erano i
materiali di fortuna intera fine metti 3
uova nel paniere wat consolle uova alle
povere farà gallina che mi fai le uova
veloce a sono quali e 123 fenomeno mamma
mia se io facessi maya roba così mia
madre arriverebbe da torino a darmi una
manganellata nei denti trova il pezzo
che ha una forma diversa questo si
vedeva subito tocca al pipistrello
ci sono un sacco di doppi sensi in
questo gioco da sarebbe sto pipistrello
scusatemi e non lo vedo stavo cliccando
albero per spostare l'albero della
scritta pp il pipistrello nou dove sto
pipistrello
non lo vedo ma neanche per sbaglio porca
vacca quanto è difficile sta cosa vuol
dire toccati pistrella ma non c'è più di
tre ma che devo muovere il telefono
vestito cento floors ragazzi non ha la
più pallida idea di dove sia studi piste
rea c'è il sole posso muoverlo eccolo
che cagata giudizio tocca in
quest'ordine vero falso falso vero vero
falso vero files france il vero vero
falso chi è bello o finalmente una
dimostrazione che il mio diploma serve a
qualcosa non toccare i pulsanti verdi
durante la partita tocca per continuare
non lo tocco li tocco sotto scopri i
palloncini rossi a sinistra verso destra
ma come
ma porca vacca come mi ha [ __ ] ma li
mortacci tua sorella
che sfiga non avevo visto scoppia le
palle dalla più piccola alla più grande
è come fare ma è un attimo come faccio a
saperlo sono tutto sono tre scopri le
palle dalla più piccola alla più grande
ma come le devo gonfiare va a cagare va
lei sloveni premi pulsanti da sinistra
verso destra 12 i verdi non li devo
prendere forse devo prenderli a inverti
la direzione ok verdi non li devo
toccare ci ha scritto prima durante il
gioco ogni volta che vedi questo pollo
toccano sempre prima di tutto va bene
tocca gli animali in quest'ordine rosa
verde grigio la zebra grigia e non l'ho
mai vista cioè bianca e nera no grigia
però ok
stai attento tocca un pò milia sosta
musica video troppo prendo una camomilla
e dormo davanti al video giuro sta
attento tocca un punto qualsiasi per
continuare ok tocca l'ombra che non
appartiene alla scena oddio che ne so
questo porto demonio morto sapevo io
giraffa era l'elefante cioè aiuti ai
piccoli pesci a fuggire e non sito non
si tolgono non sito non sito orco
demonio porchi gli squali e non posso
darli fermi tutti e due si possa tenerli
fermi
devo usare due dita scappate i miei
piccoli pesci laszlo dai da mangiare a
tutti gli animali va bene cioè io non ho
mai visto una rana mangiarsi il
formaggio però ok ha infatti la rana da
mangiare eccolo lì
l'aquila da mangiarsi aspetta il topo
deve mangiare questa è la piazza già il
toto giusto
bene tutti hanno mangiato solo uno si è
riempito lo stomaco definitivamente per
ok scoppia i palloncini ma non il primo
rosso va bene
c'è un porco demonio dotto che era il
pollo per primo che si è questa la
difficile
questa è la vera mente per gente che ha
preso più di 60 al diploma e non è il
mio caso
ecco il verso del polo era la mia tesi
di maturità ok tocca l'ala destra della
pa e poi l'antenna si è un attimo tocca
la destra dell'aprile poi l'antenna
sinistra
l'antenna sinistra alla destra del e tua
madre allora non me ne cagato mai
sbagliato a dire l'ala destra della pepa
run transitava a destra e questa alla
destra della pepco demonio tocca il
quadrato più piccolo questo è l'unico
quadrato che c'era mamma mia che
fenomeno tocca fiammifero più lungo
questo come no
come no acque li mortacci sua ma va a
cagare
per ora giusto non mi serve un
ventilatore devi morire e devi morire tu
e il tuo power bank
cosa fai attacchi il pallone ma cosa fa
ma perché vivi così premi il pulsante
blu non sono ancora daltonico per quindi
non ti preoccupare
[Musica]
abbiamo intenzione di farlo comparire
prima o poi ora siamo così il mio dio
ma cos'è ecco lo parcheggia l'auto nella
zona di divieto di sosta
porca vacca e dove la equa divieto di
sosta ma come no a fare qua scusatemi
a parte che non è il divieto di sosta
non è così io che non ho la patente
lo so che se divieto di parcheggio per
ora il divieto di sosta me lo dovete
smettere però perché non c'è non c'è il
divieto di sosta zii non c'è limite di
sarah ma ho capito così credo life
dovevi in questo era difficile trova la
ics
eccola locale no e quindi ho cliccato
dai è giusto no dai raga questo è giusto
e giusto non me lo far calcolare vi
prego faccio schifo 44 frate che non è
un ex questo punto interrogativo se
proprio vogliamo pro quarto tua madre
morta ieri
non c'è una lira eccola era così 8 di
mortacci dell'aics non so cosa ho fatto
non chiedetemi posso farvi una domanda
ragazzi ma che animale è questo che
tieni cos'è quale non appare nella
schermata precedente apre zebra uccello
coccodrillo giraffa up e roche animale
era quello spiegano lo tocca agli
oggetti dalle più caldo al più freddo
sai che cosa c'è di più caldo di questo
sì veloce clicca sette volte sulle luci
rosse va bene 1234567 molto bene risolvi
questa equazione moon o meno uno uguale
3 1 più 1 vuole due mamma mia
signori tocca tre dati differenti per
ottenere 14 in totale 13 perfetto
non voglio andare in vacanza basta è
finita l'estate si torna a scuola tranne
io che non ci va a fare i nomi dei
colori se comunque ragazzi miei mi
stupisce che sto gioco sia tradotto bene
il che è molto sindaca di tradurre
chissà cosa però toccare i nomi dei
colori secondo l'ordine indicato sopra
indicato sopra quindi rosso verde rosa
blu e grigio rosso verde rosa blu grigio
e vabbè 3 4 3 4 1 2 3 4 5 6 a 13
anna baker anna bagger let's go
se superi la seconda macchina qual è la
tua posizione più avanti di tua sorella
sicuro amici miei ancora uno e ce
l'abbiamo fatta si spera l'ultimo fa
freddo sfeir ferma al ventilatore non
devo premere i tasti verdi sacche
ragazzi basta giocare sta roba mi
impappina il cervello quasi più di 100
floors per ragazzi che vide vi sia
piaciuto è stato cioè vi giuro io devo
guardare un po di miei video per tornare
essere perché adesso sono troppo
intelligenti come al solito c'è video è
piaciuto lasciando al momento mi piace
anche a me dispiace candidato mestizia
se questi discrete via e noi ci vediamo
al prossimo vita da ragazzi
[Musica]